C'était l'époque d'internet de l'époque
à l'époque, il n'y avait pas les pokes
On va commencer on fait une dernière répét'
et après on filme totalement tout en direct sur TF1
*Faux* C'est faux, c'est pas vrai, on enregistre il y aura un montage après
Allez, éclatez-vous ! Mettez-vous à l'aise!
*cymbale*
fais moi un 200
top, recommence
C'est pas bon
le métier de maquilleur c'est de cacher tous mes boutons, voilà c'est...
C'est vrai que les pattes, ça donne un...
c'est pas mal hein ?
est-ce qu'on tenterait le " rejoignement " ?
*aboiement*
Tu coupes hein tu coupes tu montres pas ça à Internet!
J'me suis rasé c'est pareil qu'il y a 2 minutes
C'est pareil mais euh...
...c'est pour le style
*Tousse*
FUCK !
OK
STOP
*Rires*
J'aurai pas d'Oscar
Voilà
Je me produit à Bobino, je fais la 1ère partie de Norman
Whaaa
Difficile
Et ma 1ère partie de la 1ère partie de Norman !
*triangle*
Les gars, chut !
Merci !
J'arrive pas à rire avec cette moustache
je peux pas rigoler ! Au maximum je fais haha...
C'est vraiment la moustache du mec vénère
Qu'est ce que tu fais dans la vie ?
-Je suis ch...
-OK alors donc ce qu'on va faire c'est que tu vas nous faire une petite chanson hein ?
Tout à fait !
Ok aller !
...
C'était pas mal ! J'aime bien beaucoup, on peut l'applaudir
Je fais un bruitage de dessin animé
Qu'est ce que ça fais d'avoir 45 ans ? Et d'être l'inspecteur Gordon accessoirement ?
Et également le fils caché d'Einstein
QUEL EST LE PROBLÈME ? QUEL EST LE PROBLÈME ?
Y'A T'IL UN PROBLÈME ?
C'est un cache PV : ça a été conçu pour cacher PV Nova
Le train en direction de Voiron va entrer en gare voie C ! Voie C le train en direction de Voiron !
La SNCF et l'alliance Railteam vous souhaitent un bon voyage !
*accordéon*
C'est pas le moment !
La batterie c'est le mec qu'on met le plus loin possible
ça fait toujours plaisir mais je préfère être là qu'avec les quatre potes là
1973, la révolution est en marche !
Daniel, un petit éboueur du canal Saint-Martin va chercher sa mère ...
ALLEEER
Chut !
Et dans le trou de sa casquette y'a pas de mèche tu vois
donc on dirait vraiment que le mec est chauve ! Y'a juste un mulet quoi
En plus je perds mes cheveux c'est nickel !
GIVE ME THAT FUCKING GROOVE !
OK !
Thank you !